l'Île-de-France avec le poidoucharante
et la région où les établissements
scolaires ont été les plus touchés le
conseil régional va débloquer 300 à 400
millions de francs pour la réparation
d'urgence des lycées endommagés quelques
établissements ne seront pas en mesure
d'assurer la rentrée le 4 janvier comme
ce lycée de carrière sursène dans les
ivelines où se sont rendus Patrick
ferrant et Carl constable Marianne
perrick est épouvantée son lycée est
dévasté ce lycée qu'elle a vu construire
et dont elle est le premier proviseur
cet établissement des Yvelines est
aujourd'hui l'un des plus endommagés de
l'île-defance après la tempête de ces
dernier jours
je pleure plus j'ai arrêé mieux plus
pleurer mais c'est
dur 24 classes ont été détruites elles
devront être remplacées par des salalles
en préfabriqué durant les travaux qui
prendront plusieurs mois la rentrée du
millier de lycéens devrait donc être
retardée de 2 semaines environ les cours
étant rattrap pendant les vacances de
février et de Pâques j'attends la paave
pour vérifier quels sont les éléments du
bâtiment qui peuvent être conservés en
l'état sauvé sécurisé je ferais pas
rentrer un enfant aussi longtemps que je
n'aurais pas les garanties les plus
expresses de tous les organismes que les
qui peuvent rentrer dans des conditions
de sécurité satisfaisantes pas question
de retarder la rentrée en revanche dans
ce lycée du valde Marne en dépit des
dégâts la toiture de quatre salles de
classe a été arraché pour le ministre de
l'éducation nationale Claude Allègre
venu sur place la rentrée doit avoir
lieu partout au jour prévu sauf dans une
demi-douzaine d'établissements de la
région on va essayer de faire face tout
le monde est au travail des reeurs sont
travail les inspecteurs d'académie les
proviseurs et
donc on sera en état de de faire la
rentrée au mieux naturellement si tel ou
tel élève ne pe peut pas être là à
l'heure parce qu'il a été retardé on
sera un petit peu plus coulant que
d'habitude ça sera pas un souci ni pour
le gouvernement ni pour la région en
terme financier par contre il faut
trouver des entreprises disponibles des
des ouvriers disponibles et du matériel
disponible et pour le moment le gros
souci qu'on a c'est tout ce qui est
bâchage parce qu'on a beaucoup de mal à
en trouver le conseil régional
responsable des lycées va débloquer 300
à 400 millions de francs en faveur des
190 établissements sur 473 en île-
defance qui ont déclaré un
sinistre